bonjour philippe raud nietzsche bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin dans la matinale d'air france
alors aujourd'hui l'entité serbe de
bosnie vote sur la mise en place d'une
justice propre à l'entité expliquez-nous
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour quelle
raison dans quel contexte
la république serbe veut simplement
récupérer les compétences qu'elle avait
selon les accords de dayton qui ont mis
la fin à la guerre en bosnie en 1995
et on ne peut pas vraiment parler d'un
séparatisme d'un mouvement qui est qui
est
venu comme ça du siers et c'est quelque
chose qui qui est qui était prévu
simplement le problème c'est que les
autorités bosniaques de sarajevo veulent
rétablir un état
centralisé et la république serbe a
décidé de reprendre qu'il s'agit ont
tous deux de quelque 338 compétences qui
ont été enlevés à la république serbe
par la communauté internationale en
première place par les aéroports aux
représentants de la communauté de la
communauté
le dernier qui avait vraiment le support
et eva multi inzko
autrichien et son successeur qui qui qui
était
élu par l'ouest
je pense que c'était en septembre sept
2021 n'a pas reçu le support de deux
autres de deux autres joueurs importants
on conseille du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu la russie à la chine
la crise qu'ont qu'on voit aujourd'hui
elle a ses racines dans la décision de
valentine conception des dernières
décisions
de
imposer une loi qui
prévoyait des peines de prison à chaque
personne qui
qui n'acceptent pas que à srebrenica on
a eu un génocide
les serres de ne peuvent pas accepter
cette décision parce que elle mène à
la destruction de la république serbe ce
qui est étrange dans cette situation on
voit que les croates de bosnie se sont
alliés aux serbes parce que eux aussi
ils sont une pression qui viennent de
sérieux aux
premières places ça se voit par le par
une élection de du troisième membre que
la présidence de bosnie zeljko komsic
qui
sur le papier il devrait représenter les
croates mais en réalité il a été choisi
par les voiles bosniaques musulmans et
les couacs ne
ne prennent pas pour oran un des siens
le leader du parti
le plus important croates de bosnie
la communauté démocratique croate
dragan sa vie a été un
conte visite était été reçu par le
parlement de la république serbe
est
temps avec avec eux les députés a dit
que les croates et les serbes en ce
moment avec mon problèmes
sont partis en croatie au pouvoir
le premier ministre
crois tu viens du même parti que dragan
child elle va quand même moment on voit
le président kouadio général avec ce qui
qui qui prévient qu' on ne peut pas on
ne peut pas avoir une paix en bosnie on
ne peut pas résoudre le problème sans
coopération avec la serre le problème
c'est que les autorités bosniaques les
autorités de sa réelle on ne voit pas
les choses de même de même façon et
c'est avec une année où on entend bien
un contexte politique complexe néanmoins
est ce qu'un retour à la guerre dans
cette région est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
une crainte
je pense pas vraiment le problème c'est
que les juristes du cerveau rang de
grand problème pour
annuler l décision de l'assemblée de la
république serre parce qu'en même temps
s'il faisait ça il devrait proclamer que
les accords de dayton et la constitution
de la bosnie qui est basée sur sur les
accords de dayton sont invalides ne sont
plus valides d'autre côté je crois
vraiment que que la guerre où vous
parlez est ce juste du crème et là bas
on craint une guerre mais je pense pas
que c'est une réalité parce que personne
je pense que la même chose et en bosnie
on parle de la guerre nés qui peut
éclater franchement 20 minutes si
quelqu'un ne veut mais je pense que
personne n'a la volonté de la déclencher
et surtout par les cercles c'est pas les
herbes qui est qui ont aucun intérêt
en ce moment juste en quelques mots a
pour conclure à l'automne l'europe et
les etats-unis ont menacé de sanctions
économiques 1 le membre serbe de la
présidence de bosnie milorad dodik ch
comment l'occident observe la situation
sur place aujourd'hui en quelques mots
occitans l'occident comme dans le passé
été et
nous plaît du côté des musulmans
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
situation un peu différente que au début
des années 80 et surtout avec avec le
héros que que je ne crois qu'en bosnie
en ce moment dont j'ai des idées mais
leur intérêt plutôt du côté serbe que du
côté musulman parce qu'ils veulent les
mêmes droits que que quand les deux
autres peuples constitutionnel en bosnie
merci les deux
ont un
problème avec avec la volonté des
musulmans de s'imposer d'imposer leur
volonté merci beaucoup pour votre
éclairage philippe roddick rédacteur en
chef adjoint du magazine pk tu